otro frente en el campo de batalla
ucraniano en medio de los intensos
combates contra las fuerzas invasoras
rusas los médicos apostados cerca de las
zonas de acción cumplen jornadas de ardo
trabajo pero no todas son iguales Hay
días que llegan muchos heridos graves
cuatro o cinco amputaciones a la vez
otros días no llega nadie durante dos
tres o cuatro horas ningún día es igual
a otro claro Hay días difíciles sobre
todo cuando los nuestros son atacados
también pasan por ellos pacientes
especiales quienes envían mensajes de
cariño y agradecimiento
unicef contabilizó en septiembre unos
mil veintidós niños afectados entre
muertos y heridos
tenemos que asegurarnos que los niños no
mueran y lleguen al siguiente punto de
evacuación
Para ser honesta es muy difícil cuando
traen niños muy pequeños transportamos
niños sin piernas mentalmente es muy
duro cuando estás sola puedes llorar
pero cruzas las puertas y tienes que
sonreír porque ellos te miran y te dicen
ya estoy mejor
los galenos son testigos de muestras de
compañerismo solo vistas en escenas de
cine
muy a menudo llegan y dicen cóseme y
vuelvo con los muchachos
los muchachos están allí ni siquiera uno
ha dicho Llévame quiero ir a casa
la guerra que el 24 de diciembre
cumplirá 10 meses de acción
ininterrumpida ha dejado hasta el
momento cifras significativas entre
ambos bandos por primera vez desde
finales de agosto el asesor presidencial
ucraniano mijailo podoliacán informó que
hasta principios de diciembre se
registraron entre 10.000 y 13.000 bajas
fatales Mientras que el alto mando
militar estadounidense aseguró que tanto
Rusia como Ucrania han sufrido más de
100.000 bajas entre decesos y afectados